we've had an update on the Philip
Schofield controversy and that is that
Dr Ranch Singh has just tweeted in the
last couple of minutes he's tweeted a
statement so in the tweet it says lots
of journalists have been contacting me
this weekend inquiring about this so I
think it's only right that I clarify
things there's so much more I could say
but for now I hope my concerns will
finally be taken seriously and something
good comes from all of this little heart
at the end there and it goes into the
segment to give you some context
um the doctor left this morning he was a
regular on the show he left last year
there's been a lot of conjecture about
why he left since this Philip Schofield
controversy and this is now what he said
I've thought long and hard about posting
this if I'm honest I really wish I
didn't have to but I've got to clarify
some things that have been reported
about me and in light of recent events I
finally feel like I might be believed to
the journalists who've offered me money
this weekend to share my experience of
working at this morning thank you but it
would go against my principles to sell
my story especially about something like
this however given that ITV have
commented on my departure I feel it's
only fair for me to do so too to avoid
any further conjecture he goes on to say
I was on the show for 10 years and I
genuinely loved and valued working there
however over time I grew increasingly
worried about how things were behind the
scenes and how people including myself
were being treated I didn't know the
truth about what was going on with
Philip but I do know the issues with TM
this morning go far beyond him it takes
more than one person to create a culture
so I did what I thought was right and as
ITV confirmed last night I raised my
concerns about Martin frizzle's Behavior
and the environment at TM with Emma
Gormley especially given that my job is
to look after people's well-being and I
had been heavily involved in diversity
anti-bullying and mental health projects
across the channel I then found myself
being used less and less and this
statement from Dr Raj goes on to say I
even took my concerns directly to the
top of ITV the culture at this morning
had become toxic no longer aligned with
ITV values and I felt like because I
whistleblue I was managed out but as
history and experience have taught us
things like bullying and discrimination
are very hard to prove particularly in
hindsight and when quote the people in
power controlled the narrative as we've
seen no review or investigation is
foolproof still I was assured that
certain things were going to be
addressed and changes made I haven't
worked on the show since and I'm not the
only one who has spoken up or
experienced similar the statement goes
on
that was two years ago and frankly it
still hurts the whole process was pretty
heartbreaking and even affected my
mental health but I'm happy to say I've
found My Feet Again know my worth and
have found my tribe so my general
message to everyone is look around you
is this the place you want to be do you
feel valued are you thriving or just
surviving do you need to speak up
these are the lessons I've learned from
my time in this industry I say it with
all respect kindness and a desire to
make things better there are some good
people in TV but we need to be brave and
stand up to those who aren't
even if it's scary as hell we have to do
the right thing otherwise nothing will
change I sincerely hope something good
comes from all of this and he signed it
with an X so that's the latest from Dr
around Singh